agora
nas grandes questões que leva neste teto
sobre o descobrir os açores uma das
coisas que eu acho mais em santos para
partilhar é facto é que nós não sabemos
sobre o nosso arquipélago dos açores são
muito mais das coisas que temos para
descobrir e claramente cada vez fico
mais plantada que me própria com aquilo
que eu desconheço e penso que isto é uma
doença geral é todos nós
ora no processo do descobrimento dos
açores quer o nível da cultura quer ao
nível da história quer ao nível do
património a qual enfrenta o time
momento principalmente nos finais do
século 21 ao longo do primeiro porque
não sabíamos do século 21 é que
comparecer diagnosticado como uma certa
opção de tentar recolher tudo e tentar
imaginar tudo é instituto já em museu
gente terminar duas instituições deste
tipo este facto parece ser um caminho
relativamente perigoso
isto porque a tentativa do colecionar e
de guardar tudo levante para o lado
oposto isto vai fazer uma escolha sem
critério e isso parece claramente muito
no circo e por isso nós temos que
aprender a ter certa forma com nosso
próprio cérebro o nosso cérebro funciona
certa maneira a duas velocidades
nós temos uma memória muito curta que é
aquela que nós por exemplo utilizando o
número do telefone no nome de uma pessoa
e fica o comando de que sempre por
exemplo teve que tomar a gasolina no
carro e fica no memorial na zona frontal
do nosso cérebro mas depois temos aquilo
que é o mais importante que é a memória
de longa distância e quem faz a seleção
conhece diz quais são as mensagens que
ficam é curto tempo que nós crescemos e
aquelas são as mensagens de informação
vai ficar colada a nós para sempre é uma
determinada área do nosso cérebro área
do hipocampo eo hipocampo equipe já que
o que nós devemos esquecer que nós
devemos recordar o hipocampo é que eu
portanto responsável que faz com que nós
consigamos escrever e ler quando
aprendemos a fazê lo a 20 ou 30 anos
atrás
então eu acho que nesta matriz que a
forma como nosso cérebro funciona e
aplicá-la comida ao nível do nosso
patrimônio é extremamente importante
usando o hipocampo podemos fazer uma
seleção de que podemos esquecer daquilo
que vivemos facto resguardar e certa por
mês de confronto entre aquilo fica morto
está esquecido do património não teve
guardar tudo e depois selecionar é que o
que deve ficar para a vida do património
é que eu pudesse ficar sempre que nós
precisávamos da tacin para o hipocampo
patrimonial do novo pai promoverem vai
divulgar entre a sociedade
ora neste critério e nesta tentativa do
colecionar com uma base criteriosa de
uma forma seletiva tem debatido com
bastantes problemas e um deles é certa
forma o ardi crispado e o certa forma
triste como o património é partilhado os
nossos museus têm de certa forma um
olhar extremamente lucro entrar no museu
acaba por ser uma experiência e ver ser
proveitosa e ao nível do conhecimento
acaba por ser uma coisa extremamente
triste e por isso tenho sempre tentar
refletir nos últimos tempos e como é que
os nossos museus de nosso patrimônio
pode ser partilhado de uma forma mais
geral é através destas grifes consiga
pode também chegar ao fundo do objetivo
que é o conhecer conhecer é poder e
ultimamente por caminhar e extremamente
mal vista quando perguntam o que eu faço
eu digo com muita alegria sou
historiador as pessoas olham assim pra
mim com ar bastante o que é isso porque
para que serve e agora percebi que há
maneiras muito mais enriquecedoras de
perceber porque é que ser um historiador
e quando eu não ser treinada descobriu
uma alternativa à minha formação na área
da história na área do património e ter
porque a convocar através de um vídeo
muito curiosamente é um vídeo que vai e
como mora e para rir no coração de um
museu em amsterdão que foi inaugurado
precisamente dois do pt ponta delgada
abril uma ideia do dia 3 de abril e
portanto agora está na sua fase
inaugural e é um museu que vai tentar
divulgar esta reabertura depois de ter
estado fechado durante novo antes
significa que a frança prometeu carlos
machado que também está já praticamente
há sete anos e os diretores do museu
equipa organizativa resolveu fazer um
vídeo chamariz para chamar público e
este museu e é este museu museu muito
clássico com mais de 8 mil peças mas é
uma forma extremamente divertida de
chamar público o museu esperança que
também depois no interior do museu
nesta divulgação do patrimônio cultural
as pessoas sintam claramento bastante
melhor atração porque a mensagem
cultural
o shopping avenida jorge teixeira pai já
que é novo nem pó que for satisfeito no
show pensante a 727 união férias
o abc saiu em fumar y champagne campal
que nesse tipo de site em hong kong
china wang que a gente não erre vote
amanhã em niterói miséria
bom e quando não tiver nada pra provar
nossa história já sabem que o pai meu
próprio tornar uma peça de museu tal e
qual como os meus colegas do vídeo e
aqui icaraí numa moldura qualquer super
mesa
obrigada